you ready
for One Last Ride
to the Galaxy vol 3 was supposed to be
an early entry in the Marvel Cinematic
universe's phase four and now it's
finally coming to theaters if you're
here because you want to know what's
happened so far who's returning and who
will survive this gargantuan Space Opera
you've come to the right place here's
everything you need to know before you
go
[Music]
let's first get you caught up on what's
happened so far
after losing his mother to brain cancer
when he was eight Peter quills taken in
by yandu udanta who is the leader of a
group of Thieves and Smugglers called
the ravagers inspired by his adoptive
daddy Peter's involvement in the theft
of a mysterious orb introduces him to a
series of Intergalactic characters
including the likes of alien assassin
Gamora Drax the Destroyer a genetically
engineered raccoon named rocket and a
tree-like humanoid named grew yeah we
know who you are squishy I'm
it's then revealed that Ronan the
Accuser was sent by Thanos to retrieve
this orb that contains the Power Stone
an infinity stone that can literally
manipulate energy fearing that Ronan
would use this infinity stone to destroy
the Galaxy Gamora decides the stone is
safest in the hands of the interstellar
police force the Nova Corps and for
their efforts in delivering the orb the
Nova Corps has each guardian's criminal
record expunged and they are honorably
sent off as the official Guardians of
the Galaxy we'll follow your lead
Star-Lord so in volume 2 we Flash
Forward a few months and we see the
newly appointed Guardians of the Galaxy
taking on a job to save batteries from
an interdimensional monster in exchange
for gamora's estranged sister nebula
from The Sovereign people now after
crashing on a nearby Planet they
encounter ego played by the wickedly
handsome Kurt Russell who is revealed to
be a Godlike Celestial in human form and
the father of Peter Quill how does that
make sense we aren't 100 sure he's a
planet how could he make a baby with
your mother it would smush her God it's
here that the Guardians meet ego servant
mantis a lonely empath who can sense the
feelings of anyone she touches mantis
develops a friendly relationship with
Drax who tries to teach her the ways of
the world even if some of those things
might not be completely accurate I'm
learning many things like I'm a pet and
ugly once ego's nefarious plan for
Intergalactic domination is revealed
Peter and the Guardians work together to
take down ego's brain with baby Guru
planting a bomb inside the planet's core
so the bomb explodes killing ego
removing Peter's Celestial powers and
leaving Peter to die alone on the planet
but alas Peter is saved by his adoptive
father yandu who sacrifices himself to
bring Peter back to his ship to join the
rest of the Guardians
may have been your father boy but it
wasn't your daddy
for his selfless heroics the Guardians
hold a funeral for yondu where many of
his ravager buddies attend including
yandu's right-hand man craglin who
eventually Dawns yondu's control Fin and
telekinetic arrow in mid and post-credit
scenes ravager leader stikara Gord
played by Sylvester Stallone reunites
with his ex-teammates to go quote steal
some Groot grows into a moody teenager
and The Sovereign leader Aisha creates
Adam an artificial being with whom she
plans to destroy the Guardians I think I
shall call him
Adam
let's take a second now to address
gamora's history in the MCU in Avengers
Infinity War Gamora is sacrificed by her
adoptive father Thanos in order to
obtain the Soul Stone to help complete
his Infinity Gauntlet Gamora is brought
back to life in a way in Avengers end
game when Thanos time travels to 2014
bringing Gamora to the current timeline
through the quantum realm Gamora
eventually joins the current day
Avengers and Guardians of the Galaxy
though without the events of volume 1
and 2 ever taking place which of course
is going to lead to some fun times in
the upcoming volume 3 with Peter trying
to rekindle his romance with her whoever
it was that you were in love with it
sounds more like her her do not bring me
into them
knock it off now the last time we saw
the Guardians in action was in 2022's
Thor love and thunder where they
actually teamed up with the God of
Thunder to protect innocent people
across the Galaxy after feeling
overwhelmed by the amount of distress
calls though that they were receiving
Star-Lord decides that it's basically
best if the Guardians split up from Thor
to cover more ground much to Thor's
distress but when Star-Lord gives Thor
an inspiring pep talk about the joys of
love and the sadness of losing the ones
you love Thor gives him his own ship and
Ventures off to save the people of new
Asgard you've grown to a touchdown and I
knew this would happen you must go I'll
find Sif
you answer the other calls the Galaxy
needs as Guardians and finally in the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
it's revealed that mantis is Peter's
half-sister love a good plot twist and
also a holiday special can we normalize
more of these please
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present
I hope you got all that because now you
are finally all caught up we left out
some important information but
but that is the gist of it
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. from the
looks of the trailers it's clear that
there will be a conflict between the
Guardians and the high evolutionary
which is the entity seemingly
responsible for augmenting Rocket into
his current form and if the trailers are
anything to go by his return is going to
lead to Rocket finally Reckoning with
his past and encountering someone he
left behind he didn't to make things
perfect
he just hated things the way they are
meanwhile remember Aisha who created
Adam so the egg featured in one of
volume 2's post-credit scenes will
actually hatch in volume 3. producing
Adam Warlock a character who nearly
debuted in both Volume 2 and infinity
War warlock will be played by Will
Poulter and he may be on a simple
Revenge mission on behalf of the
Sovereign people Peter and his gang
screwed over at the beginning of volume
2. you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
but despite all of this looking like
another fun Guardians Adventure on paper
the trailers released for the film so
far have hinted at this being a pretty
Grim conclusion to the series from Peter
begging the others for one last ride to
draxxing it's been an honor to work
beside his friends it is entirely
possible the conclusion will come down
to the characters realizing the time to
move on has come
so who can we expect to see in volume
three the returning cast includes Chris
Pratt Zoe Saldana Dave Bautista and
Bradley Cooper along with Vin Diesel as
the voices of Rocket and Groot
respectively and Karen Gillen returning
as nebula Vol 2's mantis played by palm
clementieff and Elizabeth debicki's
Sovereign people leader Aisha return as
well finally last but not least Sean
Gunn is back as craglin now wearing
yandu's techno Mohawk and appearing more
comfortable with his dead boss's yaka
Arrow than he did in the end credits of
volume 2.
[Music]
Cracklin may be the leader of the
ravagers although that leadership role
may have been assumed by Sylvester
Stallone's Takara Gord who also returns
for this new adventure the high
evolutionary will be played by chikuti
uji who worked with James Gunn in the
HBO Max series Peacemaker so what
exactly is the future for the Guardians
director James Gunn has made it clear
that this is his last story with the
team and that his commitment to the new
DC Cinematic Universe will keep him away
from Marvel for at least a decade
meanwhile the Guardians themselves and
their actor counterparts can always
resurface in other film series should
they survive the events of volume 3. so
now you know and now you can go see
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 in
theaters on May 5th let's give the
Galaxy something to remember us by
and after you've seen Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 be sure to head to
rottentomatoes.com to rate and review
the film
foreign